>>Todd: It's my pleasure today to introduce
George Anders, who is
the author of this great new book called "The
Rare Find:
Spoting Exceptional Talent Befor Everybody
Else."
Just a few minutes on
background on George.
He is the author of four books and
is a frequent contributor to Wall Street Journal,
Fast
Company, the Bloomberg View and actually shared
a Pulitzer
Prize in 1997 for national reporting . That's
really cool.
I don't have one of those.
That's nice.
And he spent two and a half years
researching this book to basically talking
to a huge number
of people executive recruiters to sports talent
scouts to
Army special forces to Teach for America to
the MacArthur
Foundation, just a whole ton of people who
are all in
the business of finding amazing people but
maybe looking
at it in a different way than we're used to.
So I think this is particularly relevant for
Google is that we have as a lot of you guys
are recruiters and we have a very specific
way that Google finds people.
And as I read through this
book, it really turned my world upside down
thinking about a whole bunch of
different ways we should be looking for talent.
So we asked George here to talk about a bunch
of different ways
he's found.
Look forward we're going to maybe do 40
minutes for Q and A and definitely leave lots
of time for
you guys to ask questions at the end.
So welcome George.
>>George: Thank you.
Thanks for the chance to be here.
>> [Applause]
>> Todd: So one of the things I wanted to
kind of start with is
just broadly assessing talents.
So you did this.
One of
the things you profiled is the puzzle master
at Facebook
and just the whole concept of using puzzles
to select
people.
Something Google used to do; doesn't do as
much
anymore.
Can you talk about what you saw from them
and how different companies use puzzles.
>> George: Sure glad to.
We need a little bit of context history
on this one.
Turn the clock back to 2006 and at that
time Facebook is 20, 25 people on University
Avenue.
Their recruiting department is at most one
and a half
people.
They know the best engineers are wanting to
come to
Google, wanting to come to Microsoft.
There are other tech companies at
play.
How in the world are they going to compete?
They
can't get to as many campuses as you can let
alone
Microsoft can.
They're still selling a story that takes
a little while to chew over and figure out
is this going
to work or not.
And what they wanted is a way to find
the unexpected, out of the way gifted coder
who wasn't
going to be seen on the usual stops through
MIT, Carnegie
Mellon, Stanford what have you.
And they put up very entertaining and
amusing puzzles involving refrigerators full
of Red Bull
and people with stay-at-home cats and the
like but in the end they all turn
out to be database and sorting problems.
They just have
adorable names to them and everything.
And welcome to
all comers.
The simple puzzles were an hour, an hour and
a half to do.
The hard ones were ten hours.
I think they had one or two that figured were
40 hour
puzzles.
So one of the things you get is you make your
puzzles that long is you find out
who really likes to write code.
Because it's not enough
to just be able to do some of the typical
brain teasers
you'll ask in an interview which identify
people who are
very quick and facile.
This is someone who thinks why go
out Friday when there's another 150 lines
of python I could be
writing?
So that's a useful thing to select for.
So
their showcase discovery for this and I spend
a bunch of time on this in the story is a
guy named Evan Priestly.
Evan
dropped out of college because it was too
easy.
So you
wouldn't find him looking in college graduates.
You also
wouldn't find him looking in high school graduates
because he never quite finished high school
for the same
reason.
Switched majors three times looking for some
field at Southern Maine University that would
keep him going.
Nothing quite
worked and he ended up in a web development
shop and
sharpened up his skills on his own and was
a formidable
coder in a very out of the way place.
Recruiters don't
come to Portland.
The only reason you're going to be there is
you're
on summer vacation and then you're not looking
for
candidates.
So what does he do?
He answers the puzzle,
sends in the solution.
It's all automatically coded so
you can tell who's solved it right.
The good solutions
bubble up to the top.
They get called for interviews.
They come out to Palo Alto.
He gets
asked the standard questions and they explains
the answer
you want but your code is set up so badly
that you're wasting
a whole lot of time querying on database back
and forth.
If you wrote it better you wouldn't
have this problem which is total Evan.
Manners and
diplomacy are not part of his skill set but
really great
coding is.
So he gets an offer and he goes
on to do great things for them.
What I like about that
story is it spoke to the long tail of talent.
Because I think we all are
in a situation where you can know where the
best people are
going to be.
Where you're most likely to find a payoff
and the question is how much farther do you
go?
What can
you do to track down the people not just at
school number 1, or 11, or 21 on your list
but
school number 201 or the people who didn't
graduate from
school number 201.
And usually the problem is that the vanishingly
small population that you
can't send recruiters out on the road to do
presentations at these schools.
You may hire one person from them in every
ten years.
And what
this system did was to search for those people
automatically with just a little bit of story
telling,
make it seem appealing to come into this coding
environment and then to bubble up to the top
the people
who are really going to be good candidates.
So nice way
to hunt.
Not the only way to find programmers.
Probably only an ancillary way but one that
potentially
useful.
>> Todd: So let's talk about the long tail.
Because I think
that's something that Google we get thousands
and thousands of resumes
every day and we see a lot of the long tail
and a lot of
our guys spend a lot of time trying to pick
the good ones
out of the long tail.
And one of the things you talk about was the
concept of people who have jagged
resumes.
He sounded like somebody who had a jagged
resume.
Can you kind of explain the concept of what
you think a jagged resumes and how do we look
for people with interesting
jagged resumes?
>> George: Absolutely.
This is a core idea in the book.
Right
now we have an environment where we're taught
whenever we
prepare our own resume make everything look
like an
uninterrupted march of success And each new
job is a
promotion or at best a broadening lateral
transfer.
No
one ever takes a step back.
We always leave to pursue
even bigger opportunities.
We never get in an argument
with a boss and on and on.
But the fact of the matter
is some of the most interesting candidates
do have
zigzags in their resumes.
Sometimes it's the zigzag that
makes them stronger.
You can look at almost any
successful entrepreneur and part of the reason
they're
running a company on their own is because
they couldn't
work for anyone else.
You can look at people in new
fields and there may not be anyone with ten
years of
experience.
People may swoop in from unexpected ways,
self-teach themselves
what they need to know and go onto accomplish
a lot.
So
the traditional call it McKinsey, Bain model
we're looking
for the best graduates from the best schools
who did the best internships may or may
not work for them.
But especially in technical fields,
especially in fast-changing areas some of
your most
interesting people are going to bounce around.
When
I do talk far enough outside Silicon Valley
I put Steve
jobs resume at two different stages.
And if I don't put
his name on it I can briefly fool people.
And I go,
"would you fund a guy who was a dropout from
Reed College,
whose previous business was border line legal
illegal of
hacking into phones and whose appearance and
presentation
hardly looked like a successful entrepreneur."
And the answer is you bet
you should and Don Valentine at Sequoia Capital
did and that’s why it worked out enormously
well for everyone.
But you could come up right there with three
flags of why this is an imperfect resume and
you
shouldn't bankroll someone like that.
So when I talk about the jagged resume it's
a
way of saying loosen up some of those parameters
that are so
absolute that you start to miss people who
are interesting and on the
edge.
>>Todd: I think that's what we're all trying
to do here.
You
profile some interesting people in the book
who are
particularly good at doing that.
Some of them were at
the University of Utah.
>>George: There's a wonderful story in it.
It has a pedigree
too as most stories do.
When I was getting started on this book, I
had a breakfast with Andy Grove, the
former CEO of Intel and mentioned I was doing
this.
Dr. Grove, as some of you may know, has opinions
on everything.
They tend to be
strong opinions.
He is not shy to share them.
His advice to me was "You need
to go to Utah.
You need to figure out how they got good
at computer graphics because that was always
a hard area for us.
And what was their secret?"
So two or three weeks later
I'm on a plane.
I land in Salt Lake City.
I go into the
University of Utah library and they have all
the working
papers of the first chairman of the computer
science department,
David Evans.
He was the first chairman and also the first
secretary, first janitor,
first everything because it was a one person
department
when it got started.
But he showed up in 1965 and set out
to look for people who could help him explore
the
frontier.
And thats really the key concept there is
the frontier.
At that time computers were not especially
easy to use, these were still Teletype terminals
and also it was ones and zeros; it was data.
And his thinking was
there was a whole new realm that could be
opened up if we
could make this visual.
And that meant standing in
opposition to 90-95% of the research at the
time because there were all kinds of
things you could do to make computers run
faster and
process data better.
But there was this small tribe that he
assembled that said we're going to make this
look better.
And he ended up getting the ultimate founders
or
cofounders of Pixar, of Adobe, Alan Kay who's
worked on
the Macintosh and very influential, Jim Clark,
Silicon Graphics and Netscape.
They all came in as
graduate students for him.
All of them were people who
had jagged resumés to the extreme.
They had been
bouncing around.
They had been in the Navy for a bit.
They'd been working for Boeing and got sacked
in a round of layoffs.
They considered going into animation then
dropped that.
But what he liked about them was their hunger
for
Discovery, their desire to find something
new.
His
feeling was if you've got that level of motivation
and
passion I can find projects for you that will
put you on
focus.
His style was to pose six word, eight word
questions
"Could you do this?"
And the first thought was my God that's
impossible.
Someday it will be possible and I'd like to
be the person to figure out how to do it.
And it was a
talent laboratory like no other one.
An awful lot of it was just looking for these
free spirits,
unexpected people who just wanted to get to
the frontier.
>> Todd: And so, when he was able to do that,
what have you
seen in the talent scouts themselves?
Their ability too.
Because we'll see people like that and we
could hire them
and they could be terrible.
But some people are better
talent scouts at picking that out and noticing
that.
What
are the characteristics of a good executive
recruiter or a good talent scout
that you find that these guys can come from?
>> George: So the first concept I want to
introduce is managing
risk.
If you're hiring someone for a million dollar
a
year position with 500 people reporting to
him, you
better not get that wrong.
There are an awful lot of
things that can go wrong and that's a big
dent to the
organization.
If you're picking up someone for a summer
internship or for a contract for six months
you can try a lot
more experiments.
You can afford to take those long shots, what
I call in the book lottery tickets.
So how you select is important but also
how you evaluate risks and when you know when
to play it
safe and when you know to take a chance.
At one stage in doing
the book I drew up a whole spectrum chart
that streched like this.
One
end of the spectrum to the other of tolerance
for risk.
And at the far left end I put airplane pilots.
And you really
need to land the plane right every time.
You can't get someone who's got creative
ideas about landing a plane.
[laughter]
And then at the other end I put art galleries.
There you're looking for something people
have
never seen before.
In fact, one art gallery operator that I interviewed
said his main criteria for who he would
display is to ask artists "Surprise me."
And the people
who came up with something nice that's what
he went with, very successful in his field.
You could not run pilot
hiring for Delta, United or American by asking
pilot
candidates "Surprise me."
What they're going to do to the
plane just shouldn't be done.
So you need to know where
you are.
I think that's really the central idea here
is
evaluate your risks to the position.
We can talk a
little bit more about once you decide you're
in an area you can
tolerate risk what to look for.
The key thing is what's
my risk tolerance on this job and that will
vary hugely.
That's a big, long chart.
>> Todd: Can you give us some examples of
companies or
organizations where they might have a higher
risk
tolerance, the lottery tickets that they're
handing out and
making little bets on.
Who's done that well?
>>George: I got interested in pop music because
there you're
trying to guess what people want to listen
to six months from now or a year from now
and knowing
current tastes is perhaps some help but not
the key
solution.
You have to take chances.
You have to try artists that are unexpected.
Couple things that stood out.
Traditionally a lot of the
music finding and signing has been done by
people who
work in the studios that you come up the track
as someone
who develops the artist sound.
I'm seeing a second
population that's actually doing quite well
which is the
people who manage talent once it's out on
the road.
Because there are a lot of people who can
sound good in
the studio but success is as much as who can
connect with a fan base?
Who tours
well?
Who's a delight on the road and has the stamina
for it?
It can burn out artists to a terrifying degree.
So I go through the example of how Taylor
Swift was
discovered.
And a couple points that stand out here, she
had been briefly signed by one of
the biggest labels which let her go.
She was in a 15,000
a year development contract by her dad's account
was not a lot of development that was
happening and they were waiting for her to
get to 18 or 21.
She thought she could make it on the pop
charts faster than that.
She ended up getting signed by
a very small label of a guy who had just split
off from Dreamworks after that part of his
career stalled out.
And that ability when you're
running something small to take chances, to
open your
eyes to someone, he liked her sound at first.
It was
entertaining.
But we sat and flipped through his diary
and found the moment where he'd written Taylor
is a star.
And it wasn't when she first came in.
It was after she
had gone on a tour to some small Tennessee
radio station
without a record out yet just playing her
songs trying to
get station managers to listen to her.
And the
expectation was you come in you don't accomplish
anything
you come back 6 months later for another visit
and around
the third or fourth time they finally put
you on.
And
she had both the charm and the persistence
to say that "I'm so
glad you liked my song.
I think it's this time to play
it for your listeners" and the station manager
couldn't
say no.
And she was on the air.
And that's when Scott Borchetta, the guy running
the label goes "You know what?
She's the one who's going to do very
very well in the world of pop music and is
going to build
bridges to her fans and the powerful people
in the
industry that will make her a well, well-known
talent."
>>Todd: That's interesting.
That's something you talk about
what you call a slight flutter you might see
in a meeting
with somebody.
It's not, I want to dispel the myth.
There are people who the first meeting can
know this
person is bound for greatness.
They see something that's
a slight flutter and they watch them over
time and place a big bet.
How can we, we get like I said thousands of
applications a day.
How do we look for that slight
flutter knowing that there's other people
who are going
to be put in front of us the next second?
What do you
look for in that slight flutter?
>>George: It's an interesting question.
I'll offer you an
analogy from the book and then we'll bring
it back to the
world of technical hiring.
So I track down the baseball
scout who signed Mariano Rivera who's probably
the greatest relief
pitcher who's ever been in major league ball.
He was
originally a shortstop, he's Panamanian.
He was playing in a small town in Panama.
The scouting
report does not say this guy is going to win
the MVP in the
World Series.
It says this guy might have average or
slightly below average major league potential
but I think
he's worth a try.
His fast ball is a little slow right
now but his motion looks smooth, it looks
fluid.
He looks
like someone who could be a good pitcher and
key insight, he's skinny.
He's 6'2 who is 160 pounds or something.
If he fills out and once he gets on
something other than a Panamian diet he may
well.
He could become a lot stronger and more powerful.
So I think the key in knowing what to do with
the candidates who look slightly
interesting is to figure out where is their
greatest potential and
is that in a bounded or unbounded area.
Sports is a good
way to go for this because there you have
very obvious
physical parameters.
I remember watching a high school
basketball game.
There was a 15-year-old player who was playing
well and the scout said you know what?
He's as good as
he's going to get.
Look at his muscle development.
He's got
the body of a 19-year-old or 20-year-old.
That's why
he's playing well now.
But he's fully developed.
There's nothing more to come.
It's much harder when
we're talking about intellectual skills, mental
skills and the like.
But I
would come back to a list of traits like creativity,
curiosity, self-reliance.
Those tend to be baked in.
When I was hiring in newspapers, I could never
teach
curiosity.
I said I could teach you to be a better
writer.
I can teach you to be a better reporter.
If you're not curious about
people, I can't build anything there that
isn't there.
So having clear in your mind what are the
skills that I
absolutely need to have and then what are
some of the
ones that can grow out.
If you're talking about would
another couple courses in more advanced computer
programming skills working on different kinds
of
projects.
Could this person grow?
Being able to gauge
growth is really the key.
And each field will have its
own matrix.
I'm not going to try and tell you what the
matrix should be for programmers.
You know that much
better than I do.
But that ability to say here's where
the fastest growth is going to happen.
Here are the
areas where if you're not seeing it at the
time we're
interviewing there won't be much growth to
come.
I think
that helps you find the high potential long
shots.
>>Todd: Maybe I'll throw this out as a question
from the audience when we get to the Q and
A. I would love to hear stories from you guys
if you have
seen slight flutters in resumes from people
who have come
here and been successful.
What have you noticed in the
resume and what have they done?
A question for the
audience later.
Another concept you talk about in the
book that I love personally is resilience.
You give an example from
Teach for America about resilience and I think
this is a super important concept.
Can you explain what you learned about resilience
and maybe talk about that Teach for America
example?
>>George: Of course.
And let me ask to begin with we've got a
relatively young audience here.
How many people either
consider Teach for America when you were in
coming through college or
have friends who did?
Wow.
Okay so you know the organization
well just to fill in a couple of sentences
for people who
might not know it as well.
This is a program that takes
graduates from top schools and gives them
a chance to
teach for a couple years in some of America's
most
challenging and most needy schools.
It's become
tremendously competitive.
Last year there were close to
50,000 applicants for fewere than 5,000 positions.
They've
got an ability to select on any screens they
want.
And
in its early years teach for America was looking
mainly
for people with charisma, people who were
enthusiastic, energetic presenters.
And one of their stock questions
was what is wind?
And they've got people who could give
you marvelous answers about fluttering of
angels and the
like but who tended to fall apart in difficult
school
settings and you show up somewhere where there's
no heating in the winter or where the textbooks
are defaced and missing pages or
where there were 31 desks and 36 kids.
You'll never get
a chance to show them all your wonderful stories
and insights and
commentary.
You're gonna be in a position where you're
fighting to keep the classes attention.
So what Teach for
America does now is they look for resilience.
They look
for people who have persevered in their own
lives.
They
look at transcripts differently.
Overall grade point is
not as important as the slope of your grade
point.
If
you had A's freshman year because you came
in very well
prepared and then your grade started to go
down, that's
worrisome.
If you started out perhaps from a grittier
background yourself with B's first year because
you were
trying to catch the pace of college and then
you took
your grades up, there's much more impressive.
And then
they get to know people's life stories.
So one of the ones that I
showcase in the book is Emily Louis Monica
who was a
hurdler competitively in college.
She only ran for two
seasons and I asked why is that?
And it turns out Teach
for America had asked her that too.
She had a stress
fracture in her foot at the end of freshman
year and
should have never run again.
But she was competitive.
She wanted to excel.
She worked out an entire training
regimen involving mostly swimming pool work
to build up
her strength and only stepped on the track
twice her
sophomore year.
The first was to qualify for the Ivy
League finals and the second when she got
to the finals was to run them.
And she
ended up turning in Brown's best time that
year.
So that
ability to practice on her own, to set a goal,
to work
through adversity, and to win recognition.
You look at that and know what?
That's someone we can send to north Miami
to a largely Haitian community
and she'll do fine.
And sure enough she ends up being
the one who starts the before hours tutoring
program for the
people who mostly speak Creole and are still
learning English.
She helps the D and F students figure out
how to get C's and B's.
You need an awful lot of
resilience to take a student from the very
bottom up to
the middle and it's fun to work with the people
who are
going to be your A and A + students but the
ability to
say I'm going to make every student a little
better even if
they're not going to be stars is extraordinary.
So
resilience is crucial for them.
I think resilience is
crucial in almost every job.
Hedge funds spend a lot of
time trying to finding out who can bounce
back from bad
investments.
And there are lots of people who can make
money in a bull market.
But it's a much more distinctive
element to find someone who can ride out their
bad traits, learn from them
and avoid losing money in a year like 2008
when the market is just
falling apart.
Todd had mentioned Army Special Forces.
They look for tenacity, resilience, grit excessively.
They send a lot of soldiers into strange valleys
in Afghanistan and Iraq that are not well
scouted where you don't
know what you're going to find.
You're not sure who's a friend, who's an enemy.
You're not going to
storm the hill and conquer it for America.
This won't be
planting a flag on Iwo Jima.
This is going to be trying to come to some
sort of truce, stable arrangement for a period
of months
without American food.
It's up to you to find the
villager with a goat and figure out some way
to buy the goat or charm him out of the goat
or do
whatever you can so you have something you
eat.
Resilience even in the jobs that we work in.
Think of
all the projects that get off to a bad start
or get
retooled or need to be melded into some different
grand
plan and the people who can bounce back from
that and say
you know what?
That's two months of work that went off on
a
sidetrack but I'm not done yet, I'm coming
back are
the people who are going to be successful
employees.
The
people who's feeling is I've given it one
shot and they didn't like it, I'm done.
That's going to be more career-limiting.
>> Todd: One of the things with Teach for
America I thought was also
interesting was the concept of audition.
So you profile
this with a couple different organizations.
So maybe can
you talk about what does Teach for America
do for
auditions and some of the more intense auditions
you saw.
And what do you think an organization like
Google do for
audition?
>> George: Great.
So when I say audition, what I'm really
talking about is sustained careful observation.
And
sustained careful observation is too many
words and it
lacks sort of the simplicity and the allure
of the word
audition but it gets at what's really happening.
You're not just watching someone and holding
up a score
at the end that says you're a 9 or you're
a 10 and we applaud then kick you
off.
What you're doing is you're watching the whole
panorama of someone's achievement and attitude
and particularly their execution on the little
things.
This
is a great glimpse into people's work habits.
And coming
back to an earlier part of the conversation,
those kind
of habits may be the most enduring and the
hardest to
change.
So you want to see someone with good work
ethic, commitment to doing something right.
and teach for
America's case they have everyone come in
and teach a
sample lesson.
So I went up to UC Berkeley.
It was the
beginning of the recruiting season so you
got the people that were most eager to get
a job
at TFA.
And they all came in in the blue suits and
the other things you do in college when you're
going for an interview that you really want.
And
they all had worked up 5 minute lessons.
And part way through one of the Teach for
America
managers would shoot up a hand and ask a question
that
was totally from left field.
This was essentially
impersonating what's now called the off task
student.
When I
went to school, these were called troublemakers.
[laughter]
It's the same thing.
And you would then have in live time three
or
four seconds to figure out do I tell this
kid to be
quiet?
They're interrupting my lesson.
Do I try and bring them into the conversation
and
work with whatever glimmer of hope there is
in their
answer?
Do I stop my lesson entirely and try and do
a catchup
lesson for them?
There's some strategies that work.
There's some others that mean your whole lesson
plan will disintegrate.
And you can see with stark separation
there were some students who got it.
They knew how to
work with that kind of kid and you can go
into a tough
community, you're going to be fine.
And then there were
others where my beautiful lesson plan is destroyed
and I don't
know what to do.
And they started making arithmetic
mistakes.
And the whole thing would just come crashing
like a soufflé that's been dropped on the
floor.
It's a tough test but
a fair test.
It's looking for what you really need on something
like that.
So the other auditions that impressed me.
I won't tell you stories from all of them
because we've
got a lot of ground to cover.
But the key point was look not just for is
there
something about this person that dazzles but
can they work through all the
moment to moment issues?
And when you come to technical
fields, I come back to this notice of seeing
how someone codes is instructive.
In some
ways it's similar to my old world of hiring
people who write.
There's no better way to
judge someone than to give them a practice
story
assignment and we put them on contract and
pay them something for it but the result is
you see not just what the finished draft is
like but how
long it takes them to do it.
How many mistakes and
iterations does it go through?
Are these honest mistakes where you go, you
know
what, that's easily fixed and it doesn't stress
me or
are these potentially catastrophic mistakes
where you go you know what?
If we publish that, we'd be on the
wrong end of the lawsuit or we'd be hurting
our reputation?
How well
do people handle all the interpersonal stuff
on the
project too?
Coding, what's your annotation look like?
Does that tell another person enough to understand
how you wrote the
program the way you did and for them to make
any
adjustments that they need to?
In journalism the same thing.
Are you
wrapping up your interviews on a basis that
they were comfortable to talking to you or
have
you trampled on a lot of people and you've
got people complaining that you took things
out of
context and the like?
You learn a lot that way.
So it's
harder in non-performance fields to come up
with ways to do auditions but I think there
are new opportunities coming
up in sales.
I mean they're having people do
presentations.
You can tell who presents well and who doesn’t
and moving out of the just the conference
room interview to something that more closely
approximates what people do and the best way
to get
people for the job is to see them on the job
as opposed
to trying to extrapolate from what are more
artificial situations.
>>Todd: So I think when we, we have mini auditions
here where we bring people in for onsite interviews
and I think on the
technical side we do ask them to code but
I also think were
checking for what we call googliness, culture
fit.
One of the
stories you profile in your book is about
the FBI who has
a rule about, I'm not sure if I'm allowed
to swear in
authors at Google, but they don't want to
hire any A-holes and that's been that's the
single hiring
criteria that that guy uses.
And then he selected everything on top of
that.
What are some of the things we want to do
slightly
better than that.
We want them to be nice and googly.
I
sometimes talk about the people I interview.
When I don't want the
interview to end and I want to take them to
lunch
afterwards.
That's a good sign.
So are there other things we can look at
when they come onsite to interview that are
some glimpse
in to their personality.
What can we better use that audition for other
than raw technical skills?
>> George: So I like the idea of having a
culture that has a
name.
And I get to visit a lot of organizations
and I'd
say simply by knowing that you want people
with the
right amount of googliness you're ahead of
two-thirds of the companies.
And it's always sad to come into a place where
there isn't a
defining culture.
Where it's just you know turn in the
work and try not to get yelled at by the boss
or by the CEO or
controlling shareholders.
It's more of a defensive culture where there
isn't a unique way of doing
things.
Merely by thinking about googliness you're
taking an important step beyond what other
people do.
In
terms of how you draw that out in an interview,
I've
always believed you learn different things
about people
in different settings.
That we have one persona that we
bring into conference room situations.
We have a
different persona lunch.
We have a different persona
walk with someone.
Giving people a chance to show more
of the different aspects of themselves.
Reference
checks, I mean, there's perfunctory reference
checks
that get you almost nothing.
There are the ones much
more detailed.
The question that I always found elicited
the
most interesting things was to ask was "What
advice can you
give me about how to manage this person effectively?"
Because it's very neutral but it's also some
of way
failure stress issues.
Whatever you do don't criticize
this person in public because they'll go ballistic
and start
screaming and shouting and throwing stuff.
And you go, okay, that's a good tool to know
but that also tells me something about temper
that I
otherwise wouldn't have been told.
That's one way to
draw out.
In googliness, I always think part of it is
this
endless insatiable curiosity that goes in
a lot of directions and this desire to find
the nonobvious
solution that stretching the frontiers of
knowledge.
So
I would think that would come up pretty quickly
in a
conversation that you can tell whether you're
dealing
with someone who's by the book here's what
I learned in
the textbook or here's what I think the next
edition of
the textbook oughta say.
But give yourself credit.
You've
done an extraordinary job of hiring.
Every time I meet
anyone from Google I'm always impressed not
just with how
smart they are but how wide their contributions
can be.
>> Todd: It's kind of a special group to select
for that you
devote is picking the boss.
And so, we have some people
here who are leadership recruiters and specifically
trying to find the next Larry, the next Sergi.
Tell us a little bit
about, I found a lot of stuff in the book
really
counterintuitive about I would never have
guessed that's a
better way to pick a boss.
Who are the best people at
picking bosses and what do they do?
>> George: So, when you get all the way up
to the boardroom there's
an interesting question about whether you
can be both the
recruiter and assessor and I think one of
the
challenges, I spend some time on CEO searches
which you
think can go as well as anything.
We can certainly
invest more time, more advice, deeper due
diligence and yet
those tend to be some of the most frustrating
ones and
they sometimes blow up quite spectacularly.
And I think
the challenge there is boards when they're
looking at
candidates are so eager to close the deal
at a certain point that the who's
selling who relationship inverts and instead
of trying to get the
candidate to show you all their strengths
and anything
else you need to know about them pretty soon
it's the company trying to woo the
candidate.
And the higher up you go in the power ladder
the better your candidate is going to be at
this.
Remember, you're looking for leadership and
part of leadership is turning your meeting
into their meeting.
[chuckle] And I did a
profile years ago of Joe Bachelder who's America's
number one compensation attorney.
And he said any time he would go
into negotiate a compensation for a new CEO
with a general
counsel he knew he could get anything he wanted
because pretty soon, when the deal was over,
that
general counsel was going to have to report
to this new
incoming CEO and anything he said no to, maybe
we need new
general counsel.
And he could play on that slight edge
of fear quite skillfully so more restricted
stock, more options, bigger
moving allowance, shorter vesting period.
All the
dominoes justcame down just one after another.
And that's a
hard position to be in.
In the book I spend some time is
it worth outsourcing some level of the due
diligence on
the candidate.
Because then you've got this neutral
party that's doing the 4-hour career interview
and doing the deep dive and that's
picking over not just the trophy moments of
someone's
career but also the times that were bumpy
and looking for
some of the interpersonal flags that can come
up.
Yes,
you met target but you ended up with a lot
of unhappy
people along the way and maybe you had legal
exposure.
Maybe you had other things.
So that would be one area where I think
the higher up you go the more argument there
is for bringing in
outside assessors who can play that neutral
role.
Beyond
that there's a Steve Kaplan study from University
of
Chicago that I found quite impressive where
he looks at how successful executives score
on various measures of effectiveness, judged
by their
eventual performance on the job.
And he found
efficiency, accountability generally hard
virtues as
opposed to likability tended to be the ones
that drove
performance.
And we all like to think of bosses as
ultimately inspiring people who like and love
and
cherish.
But I think his point was you need to earn
that
first by delivering on the job and if you
look only for likeability then you can end
up with some people who don't set
ambitious goals or who tend to either be too
eager to please everyone to the point where
there
aren't strong priorities, there aren't tough
decisions.
So it was a bit of a tough love message.
But I think in
terms of getting the absolute best results
he's got a
point.
>> Todd: So I want to read a quote, a passage
from the book I
think would be particularly relevant to Google
here.
What you write is " As organizations grow
older, a lot of
that exuberance of early days fades.
Familiar paths
for adding talent get established.
Leaders become more
certain about which types of people they want
and which
they don't want.
Cultures turn more conservative.
Unfamiliar ideas of any sort particularly
ones that seemingly involve odd ball
hires for important jobs are more likely to
be viewed
with suspicion or disdain."
So I think a lot of us here
are worried that that will happen as Google
now is
approaching 30,000 people and is not exactly
the small
startup we used to be.
So how do we keep this from
happening?
What can Google do to not have that, not
become more conservative.
Not just keep on the same path
that we've been doing in the past?
>> George: So Todd was good enough to give
me a heads up on a
couple questions coming.
So I want to share a piece of
valley history that always struck me.
If you go back to
Hewlett Packard which to some extent defined
the best of valley culture
for decades.
I was always impressed in the 1980s with their
big breakthrough.
The thing that gave them their second or third
lease on life was the work they did in printers
and and that
came out of San Diego and that came out of
Boise not out of Palo Alto.
And I think that ability to get smart people
away from
headquarters trying new things is hugely important.
And in fact, if
you look at the early ink jet printers they
were a mess.
They were very blotchy.
They were poor resolution.
It was for a couple
of years an inferior product.
But coming back to our
conversation about gauge the upside, look
for the
opportunity.
That's true of products as well as people.
And the early pioneers in Boise , we will
get those
dots closer together.
Couple more product cycles and we
will have a printer you can be proud of.
And it will be
able to print in color and have a much faster
run rate.
It will be a lower cost
one.
And they were stubborn enough to stick it
out and
ultimately build a multi-multibillion dollar
business
in spite of a very bumpy meeting in 1984 where
the head guys at headquarters
said I'm not sure we should be putting this
much into it
and it took ultimiately support from the CEO
to say yes we should.
And I think one of
the exciting things about coming into Google
is how much
you're spreading around the globe.
I hope some of the
labs you're setting up whether it's Israel
or Singapore
or other places are not just filling in the
details for projects here
but looking for big new ideas and bringing
in the kinds of talent
that is free of whatever those pressures of
conformity may be at
headquarters.
I'm sure there will be great things that happen
at
headquarters too.
But the ability to have a global presence,
and to have idea
factories, skunk works, incubator labs that
sometimes can
try new things because they aren't as closely
watched.
And they're a little bit more free to stumble
around and
make those kinds of experiments and early
missteps that
are part of how most big breakthroughs happen.
I think
that can be crucial.
>> Todd: So we should start making printers
is that the
Suggestion?
>> George: [laughter] There's still good money
in printers.
>> Todd: You heard it here.
How about specifically in selection?
Larry is always pushing us to
think for the next idea that's going to affect
a billion
people.
And we are not, we don't quite get a billion
people applying to Google every year but pretty
close.
From selection, let's say you had no constraints
for
money, no constraints for time ,let's say
even no legal
constraints.
What are some of the crazy things we could
try given that we're Google and we have a
founder who that's not a issue for him to
think bigger.
That a find.
We need big bold ideas.
What's something that you did with some research
that you found that you think
somebody with Google scale, interesting people,
technology
what's our next billion dollar idea for selecting
people?
>> George: Well, there are an awful lot of
us who use Google
products and you know something about us.
It generally
tends to be anonymized but since you took
legal
constraints off table,
[laughter]
what can you discover from the
way people use you that say you know what?
You ought to
be part of team Google.
There may be a million reasons
why that idea will go nowhere but it's an
interesting question.
Are you finding people whose own pursuits
within the
Google universe are the kind that catch your
eye.
Is that mischievous
enough for you?
Does that send your lawyers into
palpitations?
>> Todd: I'll ask them after the talk.
That's pretty good.
Why don't we start to open it up to folks
in the crowd.
I know we have a lot of folks in recruiting.
A lot of people who spend a lot of time
looking at resumes.
If you guys have questions, come up
to the mic.
>> Male #1: So I've been in staffing for quite
some time.
There's
a lot of negative stigma around recruiters
in general and
staffing.
People love to blame recruiters and staffing
process in a lot of ways for not getting the
job or for
whatever, however the system breaks down.
Did you find
that in your research and if so, what did
you.?
>>George: So which direction is the arrow
pointing?
Is this
talking about candidates who feel that the
recruiters
didn't?
>> Male #1: Yeah, candidates, hiring managers,
people who aren't part of
the staffing organization.
>> George: Okay.
So you're looking at both sides of the equation—
>>Male #1: Yes, yes.
>>George: and you're in this challenging position
of being the
coupler of a lot of people who may not ever
couple or may
feel the coupling should have worked on their
end and
it's the other guy's fault it didn't.
I think a lot of that
comes with the territory.
In some cases you're expected
to do the impossible whether it's a very hard
search to
fill or to bring people's expectations high
up enough
they become legitimate candidates and then
somehow manage
the descent back down.
I think a bit of that just has to
be lived with.
I think as we move to a world that
there's more data that can be shared on , you
might be able
to have more transparency going into the company
of here's
what we do.
You probably don't want to have more
transparency going out to the candidate because
that
exposes you to legal risks.
I think we have to just live
with the fact job searches are a bit of a
black box.
As
much as people say they want feedback, in
some cases they don't really.
They just want affirmation.
So in an ideal world you
wouldn't have those sources of friction but
I think some
of that comes with the job.
What makes it a high skill
job that requires really bright people with
a real eye
for the situation.
If you can take out all of the human
stress you could probably have a job that's
automated and
offshored and you don't.
Yeah?
>> Male #2: As a company like Google gets
big, it develops certain
processes for [cough] excuse me, for hiring,
for
interviewing that may go against what you've
said about
being able to be creative and looking at the
different
sort of candidates.
If they don't perhaps fit into a
mold or, you know, process that may say okay
well we're
going to look at this first and this.
For example, you
may focus too much on the how does the candidate
do in
the interview setting and less on what this
candidate's
experience is over time that they bring to
us.
How would
you suggest company avoid falling into that
trap?
>>George: So Google being a company that has
a good appreciation
of data, I would think the way you police
yourself is to
look at performance of people on the basis
of how they
scored during the process and then what you
know a year
or two later and see what kinds of metrics
are helping
you find great people and what ones are not.
I know from
my journalism days, one organization I worked
with there was a painful
drop in the quality of hires when examination
of writing
samples took a backseat to how well people
communicated
in interviews.
And for about a year we hired a whole lot
of very
charming people who couldn't write worth a
damn.
[chuckle] And in
the end we're not hiring people to make nice
conversation
with a hiring editor for an hour.
We're hiring people to
do great work for a year.
And I think probably in
technical fields that's doubly and triply
true and you need some
mechanism of knowing what am I really looking
for in the interview
as opposed to what's distracting, levels of
social
connection or nonsocial connection.
There's one
organization that takes everyone out to lunch
afterwards
and uses that as a way to gauge people's sociability.
And I said has anyone ever flunked the lunch
test?
And
they said no.
Everyone passes the lunch test.
They're
all likable in some lunch setting.
Are you really
getting anything useful then?
Then it may become a sales
technique.
It may be part of how you win the person to
come work
for you.
But I think particularly in technical fields
figuring out what you're
trying to accomplish with the social niceties
of the
interview versus what's actually relevant
to the
job is important.
>>Male #2: I think that addresses part of
it.
Some of it is
really a question about how individuals in
a larger
setting can kind of buck the tide of okay
this is the
way we do it.
This is the path that we evaluate people
and maybe we, I think you made a good point
about
evaluating the people we have brought on that
does not
address some very good people that we may
choose to not
bring on because they didn't fit our predefined
notion of
how to hire somebody.
>> George: That's a very good point, the road
less taken is
hard to see.
One of the things I do with the book is put
forth the concept of jagged resumes so we've
got
terminology.
And I think it's harder when you can't even
explain what you're going at.
So I've got it into
Harvard business Review now, I'm working to
spread this
very simple but I think very powerful idea
and make it part of the
conversation.
Yeah?
>> Male #3: Can you talk more about the winning
over a candidate
from the candidate perspective especially
for established
places to find talent.
There's a big talent crunch in
our space.
And people know we're hiring.
People know
Google.
But what are some interesting things you saw
in
winning candidates over?
>>George: So I do a section in Chapter 9 about
how Johns Hopkins
brings people into its surgery residency program.
They're surgeons see themselves top guns as
doctors and John Hopkins sees itself as a
top gun school and what impressed me there
is to get
people to believe in something larger than
themselves.
It wasn't we pay you the most or you get the
shiniest
cadavers or whatever.
It ends up being you are part of a
great, unbroken century-long tradition of
innovation in medicine that goes all the way
back to William Halsted and
this is the place where great doctors of the
future were
formed and you will be surrounded by peers
and colleagues
who will help you become an extraordinary
healer to the
world.
And it's a difficult thing to pull off.
If you overstate your case it's easy to see
who's sort of
talking up a story without making good on
it.
But I
would say that ability to inspire the best
and brightest
with a sense of this is an extraordinary community
that
you're coming into.
People want to tie into an
organization.
They don't want to be just sort of solo
spores floating around.
I've looked at some research
studies on task-centered cultures versus people-centered
cultures and people stay longer in people-centered
cultures including the very best ones.
That ability to
build those connections.
But I think that has to be done
deliberately and it has to be done thoughtfully.
Can't
just happen overnight.
Yeah?
>>Female #1: So I really liked what you said
about getting people
away from smart people away from headquarters
and
doing new things.
So I think it's pretty fair to say
when people come to Google they don't want
to leave for
the most part.
So I certainly fit that bill.
But I do
have a very jagged resume before Google.
So how would
you position yourself if you found yourself
in a company
that was as amazing as Google for internal
movement
knowing that now that you are in one role
that you've
been successful in you don't want to be pigeon
holed into
just that role.
>> George: Doesn't it always come down to
that ability to make one or
two personal connections, that you need to
have a
champion somewhere.
And an awful lot of hiring is done
on who do I believe can do the job as opposed
to do I
have 20 pieces of paper in front of me and
I shuffle them
and this one is ahead of the other 19.
I think that
ability to find the team you want to be on,
get to know
the people there.
Hopefully impress them with your
ideas, what you can do, how you can build
it out.
It's a
challenge because we live in a world where
credentials
matter and some of them are excellent credentials
and
some of them are artificial.
And I'm finding this to a
huge degree with people coming back from Iraq
and Afghanistan.
They've had so huge skill
development in terms of mobilizing people,
running
facilities, safety programs and the like but
they haven't
picked up the civil engineering letters that
go after
their name so it's hard to know what to do
with them.
I'd so there's no hard substitute for finding
the people you want to work with than
getting known to them.
>>Female #2: In a company of our size there
may be people who apply
to a role thinking that this is what would
be good for them but
actually they would be a really great fit
for somewhere else in the company that they
would never think to apply to.
And I wonder in your research, did you come
across any talent
scouts or evaluators that said you know they
came across
looking in one context and said you're not
right for this
but actually maybe somewhere else is the right
place for
you.
Or maybe you'd be good somewhere else and
just sort
of taking off the blinders of what you're
looking for to
see if there's another place.
I was wondering if you
came across any scenarios like that and if
there are any lessons to be learned about
how to facilitate that better?
>> George: So you're getting into the very
challenging world of
internal talent movement.
And on this book I focused on
the external side, who do you bring into your
organization.
But you're absolutely right, some of the
internal challenges are just as big and sometimes
bigger.
In a way what we know and don't know about
our own people
can be quite jarring.
And when you're under 150 people,
you meet everyone.
They're all side events.
It's not
too hard to kind of quietly explore in both
directions.
I'm looking for someone who can do this.
I'd like a
chance to try something else.
I think it just gets
harder when the team gets bigger.
I wish there were some
way of solving that.
I don't know whether a professional
version of social network starts to surface
people like
that.
You can just analyze their postings and see
where
they might have untapped skills.
But I think you're
going to have to when you get to be 30,000
people you
almost have to solve that automatically and
through some
sort of filtering and sorting system.
It's just too hard
to knit the person to person connections together.
And
it's a big problem.
And we have an awful lot.
IBM
struggles with this.
They have no end of talented people who are
stuck in wrong jobs.
And then the question is how do we get you
to the
right jobs?
They are still working on it.
>> Todd: It can be your next book.
>>Female #3: This might not work.
So a lot of your earlier
examples revolve around an individual recognizing
that
slight flutter and taking a risk on a unique
candidate and having
them end up doing really well.
Do you think that putting people, putting
candidates through multiple interviewers and
multiple levels of approval means that those
people with jagged resumés fall out of the
process?
As
organizations grow how do we scale the appetite
for risk
so we don't lose them?
>>George: That's a big peril.
As we average in scores we're at risk that
we're
very good at getting the second decile of
people.
We know how to weed out the bottom
70 or 80%.
But that there's really some interesting people
at
the top of the pool who don't present quite
the way we
expected and pass them around to enough different
people
and someone will say no.
I guess a way you could adjust
for it is to give someone super voting powers
every now
and then and to say you know what, I feel
so strongly
about this person that even though I haven't
won the rest
of the team every I want this to be my bet
for the year
and some ability to avoid blending down scores
to the point
you're just hiring the same person in the
middle all the
time.
That's an interesting challenge.
I'm not sure
whether that would work every time or whether
the
mismatches would be there or not but you're
right.
You can
take people around to so many stations that
in the end
you lose individuality.
Yes?
>> Female #4: So my question was around the
big crazy ideas.
So I
think that there's a lot of crazy things we
try to do
with our selection processes but the big challenge
we
face is the effect that doing a crazy idea
might have on
our employment brand.
So if people are like " Oh, well Google is
making me do XYZ, I hate Google because of
it or whatever."
So I was wondering if you've seen in your
research any of these out of
the box selection techniques that either move
the needle in a really
positive way on a company's employment brand
or negative
way on a company's employment brand?
>>George: Isn't there a way to try those somewhere
where you can prototype a little bit out of
the spotlight
and find one state, one country, one division
where you can
go okay this is only a limited test.
I mean the consumer
products people do it all the time with virtually
every
product.
That way they know which their interesting
idea are and they extend them out to the whole
world and they let go of problematic ones.
I was talking to someone who runs the Presidential
Fellows Program and that's sort of a government
approach.
You don't want to upend the
whole civil service system.
It would create untold problems if you did.
But
you'd like to have these interesting small
parallel hiring systems
that do look at something sort of more than
just
traditional evaluation methods.
Do you have anything in particular?
That crazy idea that's almost worth trying
but you're not sure
whether to jump forward or not?
>>Female #3: I think that we try them and
we almost always do it in
that way of with pilot groups.
And then we find ideas that work with the
pilot group and have been shown to be valid
in terms of
hiring quality people, finding false negatives,
but we have trouble
implementing them across Google because there's
this fear
even though it helps us hire really good people
it's
going to tarnish the Google brand.
And it's something
that people are super concerned about especially
since so
many of our candidates are our users and are
really vocal
already as it is about the process.
>> George: Yeah, I'd need to know more about
where the resistance
comes in whether that's top management ,whether
that's
operating people, where you're sticking point
is.
But it
seems like a well-run pilot ought to sell
itself and if you can show
improved results in this culture where, you
know, data wins.
If your pilots really do come out that well,
maybe it
just takes a little longer to implement them
but they shouldn't be
abandoned.
It's kinda surprising.
>> Todd: Let's take one more question.
>>George: Yeah.
>>Male #4: You mention that curiosity seemed
to be baked in something that can't really
be learned.
What about
resilience?
Are there situations where somebody doesn't
seem particularly resilient but if they're
thrown into
the fire or their given the right situation
they really develop
resilience so it's really hard to tell up
front.
>> George: Boy, that's an interesting one.
I need to have a much
strong background in psychology to be able
to tell you
for sure.
In really cruel cultures, you can crush it
in
people.
Hopefully none of us live in a society where
that's systemically done, they do exist.
In terms of can people develop
it partway through their career?
I think it would be
hard to really build something that wasn't
there at all.
I think there are far more examples of people
who haven't
really learned to cope with failure well,
and when
something goes off course for them, they just
have a hard
time regrouping.
I mean a lot of the long-term
unemployed now are people who got settled
into a career, felt they did well, their
industry went south, and they can't figure
out how to
reinvent themselves.
And it's hard.
The first year will
not be better than the old system was.
It may take two
or three years to hit that breakeven point.
Some people
just have that ability to bounce back.
I think that
would be a hard skill to train.
I would think that would be more innate but
again, I'll defer to
the experts if they have other findings.
>> Todd: All right I want to thank George
for coming in.
Kind
of leave you guys with a challenge that's
there.
As you
can see from the questions there's a lot of
appetite for
trying crazy things.
That's what Google is known for.
But then we don't want to become the giant,
boring
bureaucratic process that we're worried about.
So, take a
look at some of the ideas you've heard today.
Take a look at, we have some
books for sale.
Find what I'll sort of say is a 1% project,
right?
Find something that we can tweak 1%
of the hiring here.
Experiment a little bit.
Try something crazy.
Break something and see if
something interesting and cool comes out of
it.
So I got my biggest thing reading through
the book is if I
was allowed to break 1% of hiring there's
interesting ideas in here to do it.
So if you're interested in that, come check
out the
book.
Come talk to me.
I'm happy to help you guys break our hiring
a little
bit.
Hopefully the lawyers aren't watching this
right
now.
[laughter] Hopefully it just gets your mind
thinkin' of new ways to do hiring for Google.
So thanks again George.
>>George: Thanks so much.
Really enjoyed it.
[Applause]